mr couilles à ezbet entre les deux
hommes mr barrette jour var de la
campagne électorale ou l'art de faire
attention à son environnement première
journée de pluie de la campagne libérale
philippe couillard attend le bus pendant
un quart d'heure et il éclaircit un
mystère mr khouya et sa femme elle est
plus préoccupé par le sort du cameraman
qui travaillent en reculant
on va les soutenir et informer
attention
l'équipe de jean françois lisée a
travaillé fort pour créer un décor
tropical qui évoque les paradis fiscaux
[Musique]
est finalement 50 minutes plus tard
françois legault parle d'infertilité et
du remboursement de la fécondation in
vitro et il choisit ses mots c'est vrai
que dans ce programme ait eu des abus
l'espagne raison pour jeter c'est que
ledit le bébé avec l'eau du bain
ici mathieu prost radio canada montréal
bizemont le pit a promis
[Musique]